a o
eu te falar um pouquinho sobre a
importância de promoção de diversidade e
inclusão das empresas também do país
eu uso um pouco da minha história pra
tentar conectar os contos cabeça faz
sentido mesmo isso vamos falar um
pouquinho sobre superação de
desigualdades
eu sou o mesmo carioca 43 anos nascido
em caxias sobre o rio de janeiro
sou filho do seu luís da dona elza é
casado e tem dois filhos
se eu nasci negro pobre na periferia
eu ganhei de presente uma roda de ferro
conectada nos meus pés
essa bola representa todas as barreiras
e dificuldades que eu teria que
enfrentar para poder melhorar de vida no
meu país
esse é um grande desafio é mas tudo deu
certo com o protagonismo ea luta
conseguir superar essas barreiras e vem
se a história foi feliz
só que acontece é o seguinte só
aconteceu isso que o mundo dá voltas e
hoje eu faço parte dos privilegiados do
meu país eu faço parte dos 12% de
brasileiros que têm nível superior
eu faço parte dos 5% de negros que
consegue alcançar o nível gerencial numa
grande empresa
eu faço parte dos 5% de brasileiros
e se muitos privilegiados mesmo que
ganham mais de cinco mil reais por mês
então hoje eu faço parte da elite
econômica do meu país então meu projeto
de mobilidade social funcionou muito bem
de um salto da classe d para ver a
classe média alta no meu país
pra minha família eu sou um herói é o
orgulho da minha mãe mas pra mim me traz
um grande desconforto porque eu vivo num
país que eu preciso ser herói para
melhorar de vida
é que acontece a a gente nunca chega a
lugar nenhum sem antes de reconhecer
quem veio antes
então eu gosto muito da corrida de
revezamento contra a exclusão
e se você permitir vou contar uma breve
história né que remonta lá a minha
tataravó minha tataravó deve ter nascido
em 1841 uma mulher negra escrava
sem educação sem teto sem terra sem
cultura
então eu devo ter dado dela desejo de
liberdade mas ela entregou 10 pra minha
bisavó a minha bisavó nasce talvez 1871
já com ventre livre rodando então ela
nasce uma negra liberta mas sem teto sem
terra sem propriedade sem educação sem
cultura
talvez eu tenha herdado dela resistência
mas ela deixou 0 pro meu avô meu avô já
está em 1902
um homem da roça sem acesso à educação
sem cultura sem terra sem propriedade
sem herança que entrega o meu pai seo
luiz 1933 já estamos em 33 vou chegar lá
é o que acontece um homem da roça também
mas esse começa a dar os primeiros
passos para fazer a coisa mudar quebrar
o tal ciclo de pobreza
ele consegue completar o ensino
fundamental desde os 25 anos de idade
ele numa família de semi analfabeto
consegue se formar ele é graduado e ele
consegue passar num concurso público
então ele é um funcionário público ele
me deu o que ele podia me dar
mas não faltou comida e eu não precisei
vender bailar no trem né
a escola pública com dificuldade é com a
qualidade que todo mundo conhece mas deu
tudo certo
significa que se o não conseguiu
completar o trabalho de vir a classe
média quem teve que fazer finalizar e
concluir
fui eu então são cinco gerações pra
gente conseguir conquistar tal classe
média e isso faz toda a diferença
e pra gente falar de promoção de
diversidade
o nosso privilégio se você nasce na
classe média você nasce uma plataforma
com o capital econômico capital
intelectual capital social
isso vai fazer toda a diferença se você
quer crescer na sua vida
não guardo essa informação é ter uma
outra coisa que a falar sobre
privilégios
mesmo na minha situação eu fui um
privilegiado porque eu nasci numa
família pobre de negros mas uma família
estruturada tinha pai mãe olha q
diferença no brasil
eu tinha uma família com valores morais
muito sólidos mão na massa trabalho duro
protagonismo respeito solidariedade
generosidade se aprende em casa
isso fez toda a diferença na minha vida
quantos não conseguem ter isso é eu tive
o privilégio de ter nascido com uma
coisa muito boa sabe se você nas pobres
é uma coisa maravilhosa senna ser
estudioso eu era autodidata não
conseguiu superar a escola ruim com a
qualidade ruim porque eu aprendi sozinha
em casa com os livros
eu tive o privilégio de bolsa de inglês
eu tive muita gente que me ajudou então
eu não cheguei onde cheguei sozinho teve
muita gente que me ajudou e me apoio e
deu tudo certo
se deu certo pra mim deu certo na minha
família deu certo no meu país mas
empresas que eu trabalhei porque a gente
não investe mais em gente dá origem que
eu tenho
pobre favelado negro
todos os dias eu durmo com a sensação de
que eu precisava encontrar um laser que
está perdido em algum lugar que basta
dar uma chance a esse jovem que ele vai
te contar
isso é uma questão do privilégio você
precisa reconhecer os seus privilégios
para você poder entender que é
necessário promover mais diversidade
inclusão de uma outra questão que é
muito importante que é você está
preparado para a felicidade para tudo
dar certo e se tudo der certo na sua
vida como é que faz
está preparado para o sucesso há três
anos atrás eu tive uma crise dos 40 acho
tudo estava tão bom na minha vida e eu
estava triste chegava em casa com um
aperto no coração
ninguém sabe responder que quer achar
que eu tava do
mesmo na verdade ali era o início de uma
coisa muito maior que acontecer
é como se fosse um chamado não call to
action laser você não tá vendo mais
sentido no que você construiu tá bom
agora só precisa de novos desafios novos
propósitos e tal e com essa coisa na
cabeça decidir tentar buscar o apoio de
um coach neto sobre isso resolvemos meu
próximo plano dos dez anos de carreira
fui lá procurar continental
ele até fez um plano de carreira né no
mercado de tecnologia
mas eu fiz uma pergunta que mudou tudo
os meus conhecimentos minhas habilidades
né minha experiência em que outros
mercados eu poderia atuar
ela fez um teste aqui teste além daqui a
pouco ela falou pra mim laser poderia
trabalhar com educação e política foi
nossa
realmente sou apaixonado pela educação
apesar dos pesares eu amo política eu
acho que é o grande instrumento de
transformação beleza vou pensar nisso
mas na saída ela folia vai fazer o seu
trabalho voluntário antes que você faz
realmente eu tenho a dizer para ela que
eu aprendi uma coisa que os americanos
que é o gui beck
os americanos estão um passo à frente da
gente a gente tem muito potencial mas a
gente continua do ano o que não serve o
do roupas velha eu dou lata de leite de
óleo arroz e eu dou um dinheiro que eu
participo de uma instituição religiosa e
isso é muito importante que a gente
precisa
mas o nosso país precisa muito mais que
isso e eu queria doar meu tempo e
energia eo meu conhecimento para ajudar
outras pessoas e eu saí dali fui
procurar uma ong e eu encontrei a
educafro sair do carro do frei davi lei
da vida as cotas e ali eu pude fazer o
meu trabalho vontade dá aula de
matemática num cursinho pré-vestibular e
aquilo ali me encheu de alegria acabou
com o problema lá a desinfetação
taquicardia voltava pra casa feliz né as
minhas quartas-feiras lá já estava
ciente mas mais do que isso dois meses
depois da onda ele me convidou para ir a
brasília e eu fui a brasília junto com
ele
e lá eu nem sabia direito o que a gente
é fazê-la eu queria lá brasília com ele
a gente teve uma reunião com o ministro
o ministro da educação para janeiro na
época com um pessoal do ministério
público federal e ainda tive uma
audiência com o ministro barroso pedro
para falar sobre políticas de educação
aquilo o qual está acontecendo né
eu fiquei muito feliz com isso e dali em
diante a pessoa ficar com isso eu quero
fazer isso acho que eu posso fazer e
contribuir mais
é é a oportunidade bate à porta o que
aconteceu eu fiquei dois anos nessa na
na instituição eu passei a ser o
coordenador voluntário da dadá e do cafu
e aconteceu uma coisa muito legal
um ano depois que estava na coordenação
a coca cola ea white martins bateu na
porta da ong
eles queriam desenvolver programas de
diversidade racial e fazer sentido e não
a ong que tem jovens estudantes na
maioria negros e eu fui lá para a
reunião
a surpresa foi o seguinte primeiro eles
achavam que encontra uma pessoa do mundo
social encontrar um homem do mundo
corporativo
eles gostaram do meu speedy executivo eu
sua vez eu fui lá por reunião e não
tinha a menor idéia de quem estaria lá
bastava vp de gente o diretor de rh tava
o a gerente de rh todo mundo chega lá
pessoal de comunicação pessoal
diversidade sabe quando será a reunião
tem um monte de gente é só você
fiquei meio assustado e aí eles fizeram
uma pergunta que mudou minha vida
laser a gente quer muito tirar do papel
esse programa a gente quer fazer
acontecer a gente conta muito com a sua
ajuda
como você pode ajudar a gente naquela
hora eu quase caí para trás é porque o
som de tecnologia
entendo nada de rh mas eu topei o
desafio olha vou tentar ajudar da forma
que for possível sair dali comecei a
estudar muito sobre diversidade e
inclusão que estava sendo feito no
brasil no mundo mas está muito sobre rh
seleção atração desenvolvimento tudo
retenção e comecei a contribuir
voluntariamente com essas empresas no
amor mesmo é e foi um sucesso
fiquei muito feliz com aquilo e ele me
deu em sites se a coca cola está
aprendendo está pedindo ajuda pra mim
significa que nenhuma empresa sabe fazer
então em 2016 o milan suou para ter uma
oportunidade de negócio
descobri que eu quero fazer
empreendedorismo social eu quero montar
uma consultoria especializada no
desenvolvimento de programas de
diversidade e inclusão
é isso que quero fazer quero comprar
essa luta e eu fiz isso 2016 o milan se
no empreendedorismo
criou ainda em poder da empresa que eu
libero é trago meu primo o o hotel para
fazer a plataforma a comunidade poderá
que a gente tanto gosta que é uma
plataforma de educação dos jovens ea
gente começa a desbravar sneh a a
mudança o quanto ele bateu na minha
porta
quais são os desafios diversidade
inclusão é a humanidade é plural nós
somos diferentes mesmo sabe a gente não
enxerga as coisas da mesma forma e sabe
acontece isso é bom
isso é tudo que a gente precisa isso é
riqueza isso que nos torna é humanos né
só que isso é complicado a humanidade
tem cinco mil anos de história não
conseguiu lidar ainda com esse diferente
o diferente a gente associa como algo
estranho perigoso que eu não entendo e
que eu me afasto é assim que funciona
o problema disso é que gera uma cultura
de preconceito e discriminação ódio
violência a gente sabe onde vai dar isso
então a única solução é percorrer o
caminho contrário é diferente eu me
aproximo me conecto gera experiência e
eu entendo que isso é bom
hoje a gente quer avançar não quero que
as pessoas respeitem a diversidade que
precisa celebrar a diversidade como uma
grande solução para muitos dos problemas
é continuando a a minha jornada hoje é
eu me proponho a fazer um negócio de
impacto a gente diz o agente foi
identificar qual grave problema do
brasil
temos o problema da diversidade inclusão
mas tem um outro problema muito grave
nos falta liderança brasil tomou um
risco muito grave num muito grande nos
últimos 30 anos
nós não investimos na formação de novas
lideranças
olha o ano de 2018 aí presente que nós
tendo né
então eu falei o seguinte eu quero
desbravar esse brasil eu quero
identificar jovens de alto potencial
jovens que a gente pode possa investir
para formar a nova geração de lideranças
jovens desse país
eu quero poder servir o meu país hoje
como um olheiro sabe não de futebol
mas gente boa bom de livro que gosta que
quer fazer transformação jovem que a
gente vai dar oportunidade e esses jogos
vão estar com a caneta daqui a cinco dez
anos eu espero que a gente esteja
plantando hoje sementinhas pra que eles
possam fazer uma gestão mais integrada
mais correta
a gente não precisa passar por mais lava
jato e nada disso só que alguém tem que
fazer isso agora a gente está se
propondo a fazer isso é a jornada da
diversidade inclusão é uma jornada muito
longa
as pesquisas mostram que vai demorar
oitenta anos para ter cuidado de gênero
nas empresas eqüidade racial então vai
demorar 120 lembrando que estamos
comemorando neste ano 130 anos da
abolição da escravidão porque é difícil
falar de diversidade e inclusão nas
empresas têm muita resistência porque
ela lida com preconceitos e o programa
sabe que é hoje a gente vive até tempos
interessantes é hoje as pessoas estão
saindo do armário né
os homofóbicos racistas machistas estão
botando a cara né
só que o problema maior não só esses o
problema maior são todos nós porque
todos nós somos certa forma
preconceituosos no nosso trabalho sem
saber
por uma razão simples uma coisa que
chama de viés inconsciente
o seu cérebro ao conhecer alguém novo
ele tem uma missão de entregar o
resultado estereotipa rotular essa
pessoa que se aproxima e para isso ele
vai fazer pré-julgamentos intuitivos
ele vai tomar decisões por você baseadas
nas suas memórias no que você leu no que
é nas conversas que você teve no
noticiário da tv a classificar aquela
pessoa todo o tempo a gente faz isso e
isso é que impede que a gente possa se
conviver melhor com diferente
hoje o que a gente está trabalhando nas
empresas é combater esse viés
inconsciente
é fazer com que as pessoas entendam que
a valorização da diversidade é bom para
o negócio é um fator estratégico porque
diversidade de pensamento é tudo que
você precisa para gerar a equipe de mais
alta performance que é um ambiente mais
favorável pra criatividade gente que
pensa fora da caixa é mais criativo vai
trazer mais inovação para o seu negócio
é isso vai aumentar a rentabilidade e
geração de novos produtos serviço vai
melhorar tudo se você investir na
diversidade é hoje eu quero servir o meu
país é para tornar essa sociedade uma
sociedade mais justa e menos desigual
com mais oportunidades para todos
não dá pra viver de heróis eu tenho
muito orgulho da minha história mas eu
gostaria que todo mundo saísse daqui com
a ideia o seguinte precisamos revisar
esse conceito de meritocracia
eu acredito na meritocracia justa onde a
gente dá oportunidade para todos aqui aí
sim cada um criança na velocidade do seu
talento e esforço mas sem oportunidades
iguais
a gente tá falando de qualquer outra
coisa - de meritocracia é convida a
todos que se interessam mais pelo tema
diversidade inclusão cada um pode
contribuir um pouco pra gente
transformar esse país e aproveitar essa
potência de diversidade que nós temos
essa mensagem que eu tenho pra vocês
hoje
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]